okay this you cannot write this stuff
the conservative activists cited by
Donald Trump is an authority on voter
fraud is Greg Phillips okay this is the
guy that in a tweet which I'll show you
trump cited as the guy who claims and
knows that three million people voted
illegally for Hillary Clinton Trump
tweeting look forward to seeing final
results of boat stand Greg Phillips and
crew say at least three million voters
were illegal we must do better Greg
Phillips has been exposed as a
completely and utterly deplorable guy
Phillips owes the US government more
than a hundred thousand dollars in
unpaid taxes he claims the number is
only fifty thousand he was accused of
lying about his qualifications on
government job applications he's faced
numerous allegations of what sort of
generally described as ethical
impropriety he claims to have been
building a database of all voter
registrations in the US with location
details since 2009 but he's not made
those details public he's posted online
about excessive government spending even
though again he owes the government
somewhere between fifty and a hundred
thousand dollars and unpaid taxes and
here's the kicker
you just can't write this stuff he was
registered to vote in 3-space regular
2016 election again multiple voter
registrations are not illegal if you're
only voting in one place I believe that
I'm registered to vote in two different
cities here in the state of
Massachusetts
I only voted in Boston but this is one
of the contentions from Trump that is
evidence of so-called voter fraud of
course Trump's own daughter we found out
registered in both both Pennsylvania and
New York and I guess that's why this
guy's an expert on voter fraud because
he's guilty of what Trump claims to be
looking into you can't write this stuff
I mean it's also kind of funny in a way
because when Donald Trump announced he
was going to launch this major
investigation to voter fraud yeah the
media responded by saying well you must
have some evidence here of significant
voter fraud going on across the country
yeah what do you have as evidence if
this is the guy he's going to cite some
right-wing ideologue I mean this is the
best you can do there's no credibility
there's no credibility whatsoever and it
is all I mean you start peeling back the
layers of the onion or opening up the
Russian matryoshka dolls use whatever
analogy you want this is a guy who's
been critical of deadbeat father's
quote-unquote deadbeat father's he
himself was accused of failing to pay
child support basically another
deplorable grifter which is mostly what
Donald Trump team is made out of
and speaking of voter irregularities
Phillips also said that he was
registered to vote in Madison County
Mississippi he wasn't actually on the
voter rolls there which is very very odd
Trump's going to put the best people
around him remember it is very very
clear that this entire voter fraud thing
maybe it wasn't originally conceived to
push voter ID and restrict voting rights
it probably originally came from Trump's
thin-skinned nature and insane ego but
now it's abundantly clear that
Republicans are seeing this quote
investigation as a way to justify even
further curtailing of voting rights in
advance of the next election we have to
be prepared to activate against that
I'll keep you posted as we find out more